kiev's air defenses did their job but
that's no comfort for a grieving
grandfather mourning his nine-year-old
granddaughter
the debris from a Russian short-range
ballistic missile smashed into the Earth
near a medical clinic in the east of the
capital and as children and women ran to
the bomb shelter nearby
but several Furious residents told us
the shelter was locked
many couldn't get in and had to watch as
their loved ones perished in front of
them yaroslav saw his wife die as she
ran for cover but it hasn't broken his
support for the war
to tell you the truth I think we have
more anger now because before I didn't
want to go to fight but now I don't want
to Revenge but I want to do the same
thing to them
I want them to know how it feels to lose
a part of your family
the Ukrainian Armed Forces said 10
ballistic increased missiles were fired
Kiev in the early morning and all were
intercepted but as keeps mayor Vitali
Klitschko arrived at the scene he was
confronted by Angry residents one woman
shouts at him tell us why the shelter
was closed and where exactly are they
yaroslavs amongst those venting their
frustration at him
talking to Sky News the mayor tried to
fix the focus firmly on the Russian
attacks on civilians people were angry
people very angry it's not the war is
genocide against Ukraine against
Ukrainian people from Russia
in the Border region of Belgrade several
Russian telegram channels showed
pictures of what they said were
Ukrainian attacks on civilian areas that
side of the border the Ukrainian
president who's in Moldova for a
European Summit is using every minute to
press the case for Ukraine's NATO
membership which is up for discussion
next month
and I think what is very important our
future in EU and
and Ukraine is ready to be in NATO we
are waiting when NATO will be ready to
host and to see and to have Ukraine
[Music]
the past month has seen the return of
this as the early morning call for
ukrainians in the capital strikes sirens
and sheer Terror
But Thursday's strikes on Kiev managed
to inflict the largest number of
casualties from a single attack by
Russia in weeks with the much talked
about counter-offensive yet to have
obviously got off the ground there's
growing alarm about the length of time
it's taking to start with many believing
the Russians are using the delay to
deplete or damage Ukraine's air defenses
ahead of it
and even as they were still retrieving
the bodies of the latest dead in the
capital more Sirens sent the residents
scattering and running to hide the
tensions arising here Alex Crawford Sky
News Keith